Weißt du jetzt was aus der Frage ist?
Von
easy as f**k
die schrems nicht mitgekriegt
dann posten wirs jetzt mal
wenn die leute schon freiwillig zugespammt werden wollen
da wollen wir mal nix dagegen sagen, oder?
omega logo
skirmast
oder ist das jetzt klickbar?
ich hab gedacht ich mach mal ein bisschen kühlende musik an
das kühlt
so
twitter post ist raus
anzeige ist raus
abmahnung ist raus
bestellung ist raus
alles ist raus
also das mütze ist raus
so
ok leute ich bin am start
ich muss jetzt nochmal kurz mein iphone anschließen
dass das auflädt, weil das ist gleich leer
und dann gucken wir uns das teil mal an
ich muss hier bei meinem chaos mittlerweile fast aufpassen
dass ich nichts herunerschmeiß
nur wenn ich ein handy per usb anschließe
muss echt mal wieder aufräumen
das ist echt
das wo ich gerade bin ist so ein hybrid aus arbeitszimmer
gamingzimmer
und bastelzimmer
das ist komplett
alles in einem
das ist richtig pepega zimmer
eigentlich
das vor allem siehts hier aus
amazon kabels
verpackung fast bis zur decke
in der einen ecke
jetzt darf der mal ein bisschen leiser song of storm
so
ok
dhl war vorhin da
also quasi einen tag später
als sie es eigentlich zustellen wollten und haben es zugestellt
also kann ich nur sagen
aber immerhin ist es da
gerade mal kurz update anschmeißen
wir müssen uns jetzt mal ganz schnell überlegen
was wir alles testen wollen
ich hab mir schon ein paar sachen aufgeschrieben
ich kann nicht mal mal tippen heute
grausam oder
hallo x der
luigi x
musik lautstärke müsste jetzt glaube ich ziemlich gut passen
gerade passen als hintergrund
schallung
der dhl man hat bei dir einen 3d drucker gebracht
ok das war natürlich ein bisschen größeres paket
was hast du gekauft
ich dachte mir
dass es luigi tut
ich hab das grad absichtlich nur ein bisschen
ein bisschen hier
was hast du für einen 3d drucker geholt
kaskorian
ja gut das ist ja so der einsteiger
tip schlechthin
aktuell so eines der
mitgehyptesten 3d drucker
aktuell gibt es ja auch zig anleitungsvideos
und zig mods und alles
ich hab übrigens noch aufgerüstet
ich hab euch ja letztens gezeigt
das case was ich ausgedruckt hab für mein lora gateway
ich hab's jetzt auch ein bisschen
aufgerüstet ich hab's jetzt
so gemacht dass
ich hab eine neue antenne drauf gemacht das ist jetzt was ich komplett weiß
und die antenne schließt dann oben
auch bündig bündig ab und die antenne
ist größer
größer antenne besser
chocolate update
ein scoop update
ich rüssel studio
code auf
also
bleib hier weg
was geht jetzt
nicht rum ey
the fuck rüssel studio was geht hier
was ist was was ist das problem
das ist ja hier
und warum will
rüssel studio mal network accessen
naja ok oh ne jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt ist die kamera wieder kaputt oder
ha aber ich weiß jetzt wie ichs fixe leute
ich weiß wie ich die kamera fixe
hop
wey geht wieder
muss einfach szenen umschalten
nice
habe ich hier habe ich die
arduino ide ach so
ein stall braucht doch kein
mensch hier drauf deswegen hat er auch gerade so rumgespackt
also was wir jetzt machen heute ist was ich mir
überlegt hab also wenn wir testen auf jeden fall
erstmal einfach io performance
von dem ding
einfach gucken was was packt das
ding dafür hab ich ne
hab ich hier nen
ja nen china
adapter aber ich hab mit zweifelsfall auch
noch einen shakun usb
sata adapter
allerdings ist der china adapter deutlich
billiger das ist nen china usb 3
usb 3 auf sata
direkt mit strom und allem dabei
musste einfach usb anschließen ist kurz
und als ssd habe
ich dran eine das sollte mehr
als genug performance sein habe
ich dran eine crucial mx
500 500
gigabyte da gucken wir
mal schnell was das ding
theoretische performance macht
guck mal was das kann
wann ist das
paket nur gekommen vor einer
stunde ungefähr
also ziemlich genau
einen tag später als wir es einspringen wollen
so sequenziell
ok das reicht
ähm
ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher was was schafft
ein usb 3
was schafft es denn
theoretisches maximum
ok 640
640 schwingarbeit
da geht aber noch so viel
overhead gedöns über drauf
dass wir wahrscheinlich mit einer 500
500 mb die sekunde ssd
ziemlich gut zum testen aufgestellt sind
ich sagen
achja ich muss ich könnte ja mal
mein fragentool anmachen
oder was sagt ihr
könnt mein fragentool mache ich an
das ist zwar noch nicht ganz
fertig aber das könnte uns
das könnte uns ja schon was bringen dass das das
question
question board was auch immer wie wir das ding nennen
dann
ok
ok leute ihr könnt jetzt mal testen ob das
funktioniert
nein testet es nicht
dann wird es ja voll gespammt
aber der trick war jetzt ja eigentlich
habe ich euch debatet weil wenn ich sage
twitch chat mach was nicht
dann macht es twitch chat erst
the fuck
warum hat das jetzt gerade mein
usb studio code auf den anderen desktop
ja
kann das sein das nicht funktioniert
jebaited
mein chat tool ist kaputt
warum warum ist es kaputt
was ist da los
ok nochmal nochmal
testen
alles kaputt jetzt jetzt
können wir testen jetzt jetzt können wir testen leute
jetzt jetzt können wir testen
mach mal
add wo plus
ha
jetzt funktioniert es
poke is
nee poke
nee
hast du mir
studio key einlesen können das geht nur mit account
stimmt
ich wollte ja wlan repeater eine firma
oder mail schreiben
ok
aber gut
sehe ich das hier gar nicht mehr
aber ich kann mir merken wo ich war das
schonmal nicht schlecht
ok
nice
ach jetzt weiß ich warum das rumspackt
ich hab das auf dem falschen desktop
oder wie mein
vater immer gesagt hat
kam es auf dem falschen deskop
der hat bis heute nicht verstanden dass es desktop heißt
und nicht deskop
aber so ist das mit älteren leuten
und internet da machst du nix
in der sudo
ey das tool ist echt praktisch
so dieses fragenanzeige ding
in der sudo hast file
no pass video all oder besser nicht
es kommt drauf an was du
vorhast
so respite
das kann man schon machen
ich schränke
eigentlich auch meistens nix ein
was man sudo mäßig macht
klar du kannst sudo sagen
oh nee ich kann meinen tick nicht ausleben
oh das ist bitter
kannst du über die library time machen oder schreiben
oder kann man nur die nachrichten
das ist ein ultra billig tool was wir gestern
zusammen gekloppt haben im stream
was einfach alle fragen
mit entwupplos mir aufliste dass ich nix
über sehe
ahja
do you allow typing during debug
yes
sehr schön
kann man das jetzt noch
minimieren
ich kanns einfach an desktop schieben
bam
minimieren emi 3 klar geht
kein problem
kannst ohne probleme vlc starten
und minimieren
solange du in system tray
hast du es kein problem
das program muss es halt können
ok leute also
fangen wir mal an
wenn euch noch was einfällt was wir testen wollen
schießt los
stimmt tatsächlich
ist das wirklich der 8te stream in folge
krasser scheiß oder
wird dort nicht einfach das
fenster geklaut sein dann wenn du system tray offen hast
das program minimieren kann dann
dann geht das
bald partner
ja demnächst kann ich mich wieder bewerben richtig
also wenn euch was einfällt
sagt bescheid also wir testen jetzt erstmal
io performance
mit der ssd wie gesagt ich habe hier
im usb 3 auf
sata adapter
damit probieren wir das danach machen wir mal
einfach tcp
ohne großartig was drüber
performance test gucken wie viel da drüber geht
ja da sollten dann irgendwas
irgendwas um 100 keine ahnung
theoretisches maximum bis 125 mb
was weiß ich 120 mb oder so
sollten da drüber gehen
das ist ne sache die mir wichtig ist
da testen wir lux performance
lux neben sagt das was
ist lux
ja sehr gut
ja der kalif weiß bescheid
und der casco weiß auch bescheid
verschlüsselung
linux fragt mich nicht wofür
steht
was steht lux
linux unified key setup
ok mein wegen es ist
verschlüsselung
danach testen wir die samba performance
das ist eigentlich das was die meisten
leute primär interessiert
unterm strich dann was ihr
zwar sagen wir nass an performance hat
das ist halt windows gedöns
und dann gucken wir uns auch nochmal an was die cpu ungefähr kann
ich hätte auch noch ein usb 3
zum vergleich hier
aber ich glaube soweit müssen wir gar nicht gehen
da kommt ja ausbilder raus
in die leute im chat fragen was ist das
ich erzähle ja öfters
ich muss ja mal überprüfen ob das auch
hängen bleibt ja
so ich mache jetzt mal auf
mein twitter post
ist jemand über twitter da
ja ok schön
dann weiß ich auch dass der link geht
geht
und das
bild auch funktioniert
gut
dann würde ich sagen legen wir mal
los es ist
echt krass warm heute ich weiß nicht
was ich jetzt hier ohne klima anlage mache
und wir
müssen als erstes mal einen neuen
das neue raspian runterladen
denn es gibt mit dem zu dem release
einen tag später oder so
oder am gleichen tag zumindest
zum download gibt es das gleiche glaube ich
erst offiziell seit gestern seit dem release
vom raspberry pi 4 gibt es auch hier
ein neues debian
ein neues raspian nämlich buster
buster ist der hund aus toy story der hier
wer sich fragt wo die namen herkommen
das ist das ist buster
was ist das dachte buster
war den den man lang ziehen kann
der hund der außer zwei hell
besteht das nicht buster
also immer das ist
buster deswegen heißt das so
nimmst du auch gleich 64 bit
nein ich nehme erst mal kein 64 bit
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob es überhaupt
64 bit raspian gibt
das war bisher immer 32
bit
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass sie das geändert haben
da sind ja auch sau viele libraries und
dinge abhängig und die ganze
raspberry ökosystem
lebt ja irgendwie
von rückwärtskompatibilität
deswegen wird es eine weile dauern
soll ich die musik lauter oder leiser
oder passt das so
soll ich irgendwie was für lautstärke ändern
ok laden wir
den kram erst mal runter
minimal ohne desktop light
wollen wir haben
musik passt sehr schön
laden wir das mal runter das dürfte jetzt ja relativ
relativ schnell gehen jawoll 12mb die
sekunde
lutscht einmal
es sackt quasi
und dann ist es
down gelodet
wo war jetzt eigentlich
in dein was
ne der hat den gestern einfach nicht mal ausgetragen
hatte keine mock mehr war gestern zuviel
gestern deinen verlängerten stream mitbekommen ja habe ich
ich hab dann umgelockt auf
meinen anderen account
und hab festgestellt
dass ich gucke dann
immer noch was es für clips gab
und überhaupt
was auf dem channel so passiert ist
das video ist
jetzt erst on und da hab ich das video mal angemacht
hab festgestellt ich hab da noch
ne weile ins mikro quasi
geatmet nachdem ich eigentlich off war
ich frag mich nicht wie das funktioniert
weil eigentlich hab ich cyrus gehostet
und danach gehts direkt
weg
normalerweise der stream aber irgendwie war das ja
es hat gesagt
es hat kurz gehostet
und danach war ich wieder da
ganz merkwürdig
ja ab
ab august
hab ich da
unity media 440 ab
und telecom ist gekündigt
telecom hat bei mir richtig gesagt
massive huge gesagt
ich brauch ne sd karte
wir nehmen einfach die sd karte
aus dem raspberry pi 3
weil
man muss jetzt keine
sd karte aufmachen
ich hab gelesen bei vodafone
kann man aktuell sich noch glasfaser
ins haus legen lassen
wenn man das grundstück gehört
aber angeblich
geht das nur noch bis august
ob da was dran ist
gucken wir mal
wir flashen jetzt erstmal
das neue
espion
hast du was um die stromaufnahme zu messen
ja das ist ne sehr gute sache
zugucker
das nehm ich gleich mal mit auf
so
quasi requests
das tool ist praktisch
oder? sag doch mal
für das das wir das gestern so in einer stunde zusammen gewurstet haben
das ist doch wirklich praktisch
obunto macht angeblich jetzt doch 32bit rein
ja stimmt ich brauch ne
ja das ist jetzt einfach konsole
append only
bauen wir noch, bauen wir noch alles ein
in das tool dass man das auch schön abhaken kann
weil ich glaub das ist auch wieder ein tool was andere streamer auch gebrauchen können
so
download ist fertig
sd karte ist dran
mal gucken
ich muss noch kurz gucken was sd karte ist
sdb ok
headshores
hallo pal dadini
es ist
jetzt wo ich das mal auf twitter gepostet hab
komm ganz komisch
die hier die hab ich alle nicht gesehen
ja ganz viele
hab ich nicht gesehen hier
der pal dadini
hab ich nicht gesehen
kaskoria hab ich nicht gesehen
der luigi den könnt ihr schon mal gesehen haben
nico 1811
hab ich glaub ich auch noch nicht gesehen
paxi 13
hab ich auch nicht gesehen
nikoro hab ich noch nicht gesehen
der franka 98
also scheinen paar über twitter da zu sein
the hook
den hab ich glaub ich schon mal gesehen
2 years ago
oder alex v oder wills wissen
ok
moment wo
was betreffend ist man
download ordner
download
buster
16g ssd
bb
flashen
ich glaub ich muss die raspberry schon mal auspacken
ich musste ein bisschen suchen bis ich einen usb c kabel gefunden hab
ich hab genau 2 usb c kabels
im ganzen haus
1 hab ich nicht gefunden und 1 hab ich zum glück gefunden
mikro usb ich weiß ja nicht wie es euch da geht
aber mikro usb kabel hab ich quasi zum
Da kann ich mich zudecken mit
Aber usb-c kabel habe ich kaum
Kann sein dass die musik vorbei ist
Ach ne, ich geh einfach wieder von vorne los
Hdmi, hdmi 2 hat er, klinke ausgang hat er, kamera wie gewohnt
Gut hdmi schließen wir jetzt nicht an, wozu?
Wir schließen jetzt einfach mal an, wir machen jetzt einfach die micro sd karte rein
und schließen mal den netzwerk kabel an
Dann schauen wir mal
Und ich hoffe die netzwerk konfig das mit dem touch ssh funktioniert unter buster auch noch
Gucken wir mal
Klinke, ja das, der raspberry hat das was apple und so alles schon, was die alles schon abgeschafft haben
Der hat nen klinkeanschluss
Es sieht zumindest stark nach nem klinkeanschluss aus
Ich hab's ehrlich gesagt noch nie
Noch nie ausprobiert, ich stöpsel mal kurz was dran aber das ist bestimmt ein klinkeanschluss
Ja das ist ein klinkeanschluss
Was auch ganz praktisch ist
Du hast theoretisch beim raspberry die Möglichkeit kannst du jetzt mittlerweile
Ton und video über hdmi, das ist jetzt wie micro hdmi oder sowas
Das sieht aus wie micro usb plus dass das hdmi ist, das sieht wirklich fast original aus wie usb
Dann haben wir unverfahrenden klinkelstecker
Nicht schlecht
So, er hat geflasht
Das was man bei jedem raspberry machen muss
Dann muss das ding mounten
Sdb1, dann muss das mounten und dann geht man auf die sdkarte und sagt touch ssh
Das ist ganz wichtig, weil ansonsten kann man sich auf den raspberry nicht einloggen
Und das ist nicht gut
So, ssdkarte ist, ich sag immer, warum sag ich eigentlich immer, ich bin total bescheuert
Ich sag ssdkarte und ich sag gebrand
Oftmals in Kombination
Wir haben die ssdkarte gebrand, das kann eigentlich viel falscher gehen
Viel verkehrter kann man das auch gar nicht mehr sagen
Aber es brennt ssdkarten nicht und es ist auch keine ssdkarte
Dann machen wir mal rein
Im Prinzip sieht das hier alles sonst noch aus wie ein ganz normaler raspberry immer so ausschaut
Und jetzt schließen wir mal hier Netzwerkkabel
Ups, Netzwerkkabel
Achtung, klick
Und jetzt kommt Strom dran
Und dann gucken wir mal ob es funzt
Leuchten tut es schon mal
Flimmern tut es auch, das heißt wir können uns da gleich per ssh einladen
Ich guck grad mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm nach
Was das Ding für eine ssh, äh für eine ip gekriegt hat
IP, dhcp, server, leases
Ok noch gar keine
Der braucht wahrscheinlich einfach ein bisschen bis er gestartet ist
Ja der blinkt auch noch wild vor sich hin, der wird gleich starten
Fahren wir noch mal eine Minute rein
Der ssdkarten brennt benutzt auch cybernukes
Ja das mit dem Unterschied, dass diese Geschichte da in dieser tv-serie mit der cybernuke garantiert von leuten gemacht wurden
Die kein Plastenschimmer haben, wie, wie quasi, ich will noch nicht sagen wie Hacker arbeiten
Sondern, sondern überhaupt wie man, wie man irgendwas anderes außer mails in Outlook abrufen macht
Ja Flo96 kann sein, dass man da auch noch irgendwie ssvideo oder irgendwie sowas ausgang drüber machen kann
Der Luigi sagt, ich weiß, dass du vor zeit mal ein top tool video gemacht hast, da war auch irgendein ssh tool bei, welches war das nochmal
Äh ich glaube cmd war das, so ein terminal für windows
Ich glaube cmd war das
Wie gut kennst du dich mit javascript aus, gut genug, dass ich damit webseiten machen kann, aber Spaß hab ich nicht unbedingt dran
Ah hier, der raspberry ist da
Pi, add, 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, yes, raspberry
Da isser
Bam
Cut, proc, cpu info
Kommen wir uns angucken was drinnen ist, cpu info
Da isser ein arm v7 bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
Wird da nicht der takt normalerweise auch mit dabei
Ok, anscheinend nicht, man ist die ausgabe crap, kann man nicht gebrauchen
Ähm, so jetzt installieren wir als erstes mal die wichtigsten sachen, die man immer installiert, wir machen erstmal ein paket update
IP leaked, monkaS
IP, jetzt ist der dedos nicht mehr weit
Was wird den raspberry pi gemacht, erstmal gucken was der neue kann
Und wie schnell das netzwerk ist, das interessiert mich eigentlich
Hast du die 4 gigabyte variante, ey ich steh doch so geil im titel vorm streben
She baited, ja genau
So, I'm great
Erstmal paket updates machen, weil ich hab schon gelesen so im internet, dass das doch schon für raspberry verhältnisse recht experimentell ist an manchen stellen
Zum beispiel funktionieren wohl die hdmi ausschlüsse nicht mit voller auflösung oder voller bildrate und sowas
Das ist also noch alles recht neu, das heißt da schadet es auf jeden fall nicht, wenn wir ein paket update machen, was
Ja paket update
Ich verkauf die HTTPS zertifikat ab 5000 euro, ey gib check alter, wird gekauft
Das haben wir früher total beknackt, heute sagste high five, in der schule haben wir immer gesagt ey alter gib check, frag mich nicht warum, was soll immer check
Heute machen die leute aber nicht mehr check, heute machen die leute profist
Mal wird geprofistet
4 gigabyte könnte, also die ssd, äh die sd karte 16 und ram ist 4 gigabyte
Guck mal hier, der macht auch schon ordentlich updates von irgendwelchen binary driver geschichten, also das ist auf jeden fall gut, dass wir hier ein update machen
Äh hier warum hast du, warum fragst du wegen javascript
Wie hast du dein i3 status so hinbekommen, ähm
Indem ich nicht i3 status nehme, sondern i3 status rs heißt das glaube ich
I3 status rust, das hab ich, und du brauchst einen composite manager, dass du so sachen transparent machen kannst
Und eine config datei dafür, wo du dann ein paar icons einträgst und so, allerdings ist es kein normales i3 status, es ist i3 status rust
Plus Compton, der travel weiß Bescheid
Und im Prinzip die desktop icons sind ganz normaler icon font, man muss halt einen icon font finden, der einem gefällt
Man braucht eine halbwegs neue, glaube ich, i3 Version, dass das hier color, also bundliche icons sein dürfen und es muss ein color font sein, der das irgendwie unterstützt
Ja und die Hintergründe, die wechseln, das ist ein ganz normales login script, was einfach beim login die Hintergründe wechselt
Denkst du Nvidia wird dir noch irgendwelche gratis Sachen schicken, ja wenn ich irgendwann mal wieder auf YouTube ordentlich was mach, sodass es für Nvidia interessant wird, warum nicht
Wie viel verdienst du als Fachinformant, ähm
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das erzählen soll, warum eigentlich nicht, den muss ich auch mal Gedanken drüber machen, ob ich das mal ein bisschen näher erzähle
Auf jeden Fall, man verdient prinzipiell immer zu wenig
Partnerbewerbung, ja diesmal, wenn ich jetzt noch ein paar mal gestrieben habe, mache ich wirklich Partnerbewerbung
Wir haben den Raspberry endlich an, ja wir sind schon drauf eingeloggt, so, Update ist gemacht
Update ist gemacht, wir rebooten mal, man weiß nie
Diese Geschichte mit Geld redet man nicht, das finde ich prinzipiell irgendwie unsinnig, außer man ist da irgendwie verpflichtet vertraglich
Wobei das auch eine Frage ist, das ist auch rechtlich nicht so einfach
Aber an sich finde ich das nicht schlimm, was viel eher das Problem ist, das was mir so auffällt
Nicht unbedingt bei uns, dadurch dass man halt sagt so nach dem Motto, ey Leute redet nicht drüber
Kann das halt auch dazu führen, dass quasi in mehr oder weniger gleichen Positionen mit ähnlicher Verantwortung
Mit ähnlichem Aufgabenbereich, dass die Gelder total unterschiedlich sind
Und natürlich tut man da gut daran, wenn man als Arbeitgeber sagt, ey Leute redet mal da nicht drüber, weil da fällt das keinem richtig auf
Aber bei uns haben sie es eh komplett verkackt
Wir wissen mittlerweile recht genau untereinander, was die anderen verdienen, weil sie es mal geschafft haben
Die Abrechnung von einem Team einen Jahr lang nicht richtig zu machen
Da kann keiner erwarten, dass man sich nicht mal austauscht und nach dem Motto, ey sag mal, war deine richtig?
Und seitdem wissen wir es eh mehr oder weniger
So, mal gucken ob der Raspberry wieder da ist
Achso, wir müssen nochmal, ganz wichtig SSH, Copy ID, Raspberry
Dann brauchen wir nie wieder Passwort eingeben
Einfach mit seinem Key angemeldet
Das ist sehr praktisch, das ist immer das erste was ich machen würde
Also wir haben doch ganz viel Song of Storms vor uns heute
Ok, gucken wir mal ob wir jetzt alle neuen Updates drauf haben, aber wahrscheinlich
Und dann installieren wir mal Susbench
Also wir installieren jetzt erstmal die Standard Tools, die ich immer installiere
T-Max, Git, Vim, H-Top, D-Stats und eins vergesse ich immer
Leute ihr wisst wahrscheinlich besser, was ich vergesse
Was installiere ich sonst noch immer?
Voll PP-Gerhirn, ja
Und wenn es keinem einfällt, ich vergesse immer irgendwas, irgendwas vergesse ich immer zu installieren
Teamspeak, ja, ASCII Qual
Ok, euch fällt es auch nicht ein
Dann installieren wir jetzt erstmal
Tun sie das nicht?
Keine Ahnung
Ok, anscheinend ist es komplizierter als man denkt
Ja, irgendwie sowas
Ok, ich habe noch nie etwas in Scala gemacht
Übrigens danke für die ganzen Follows, sehr, sehr nice
Ich habe noch nie etwas in Scala gemacht
Das einzige was ich auf Java vm Basis gemacht habe bisher ist Groovy
Ok, jetzt haben wir alles installiert, schauen wir was H-Top sagt
Sensor, VC, GEN, TEMP
Warte so
50 Grad, ok das ist schonmal ganz ordentlich
OUCH
Wird gespendet
Also shit
Dankeschön
2 Euro, 2 Tag halb
Damit er max motiviert bleibt
Eigentlich bleibe ich schon motiviert wenn die Leute zugucken
Das reicht mir ohne Scheiß
Also mittlerweile bin ich da...
Ich bin da eigentlich ganz zufrieden
Ähm
Ich muss mal sagen ich muss mal dringend
Mal
Ganz schnell
Und ganz kurz
Mal wohin
Weil ich bin mehr oder weniger heimgekommen
Hab mir was zu trinken gemacht
Und hab mich jetzt an den Rechner gesetzt
Ich muss mal
Aufgekloppt
Sensor, GEN, TEMP
Sensor, VC, GEN, TEMP
Test
Test, Test
Ah
Oh
Ich hab Mangelkontakt
Moment mal
Warte mal
Hallo
Test, Test
Ah wunderbar
Äh
Irgendwie hat es gerade rumgespackt
Ja also Leute ich bin wieder am Start
Aber nicht dass ihr denkt der Chat wäre unbeobachtet gewesen
Während ich im Klo war
Natürlich war ich mit der Twitter App am Start
Hab den Chat weiter gestalkt
Vom Klo aus
Und deswegen habe ich festgestellt
Hier gibt es gerade Diskussionen
Was Kühlkörper auf dem Raspberry bringen
Ich hab zwar leider keine
Keine richtigen
Raspberry Kühlkörper mehr
Aber was ich da habe ist
Das können wir dann nämlich mal ausprobieren
Das machen wir jetzt mal
Wir machen jetzt mal richtig Dampf auf diesem Ding
Wir machen jetzt mal richtig, richtig Dampf auf dem Raspberry
Also richtig alle vier Kerne auslasten
Schauen mal dabei
Was das Ding für eine Temperatur braucht
Und dann machen wir einen Passivkühler drauf
Was ich als Kühler da habe ist folgendes
Das müsste denke ich auch ganz gut funktionieren
Wartet mal kurz
Ich zeig es euch
Nein Amazon
Ich will nicht meine
Mobiltelefonnummer jetzt hinterlegen
Muss mal kurz auf Amazon raussuchen
Was ich
In der Kühler
Ich hab nämlich letztens ein paar kleine Kühler
Kühlkörper gekauft
Das hier
Davon habe ich welche da
Ich mein die sollten ja für den Raspberry auch ganz gut funktionieren
Da sind zwar eigentlich für Spannungswandler
Aber die sollten ja eigentlich auch für den Raspberry gehen
ChatTool hat den Chat beobachtet
Mein ChatTool hat auch den Chat beobachtet
So also wir machen jetzt mal richtig Dampf auf dem Raspberry
Aber erstmal muss ich schauen ob das überhaupt das richtige Kommando ist
Ciao Raspberry Pi Temperature
Ok Measure Temp
Measure Temp ist
Richtig auf jeden Fall
Ok dann machen wir jetzt mal einen T-Max auf
Und starten einfach 4x
4x was zu rechnen
Zuschauer fragt Max
Nachdem du nicht mehr so gerne Videos machst wie ich rausgehört habe
Meinst du
Du kannst mal in einer VM zeigen
Wie du dein Linux so installiert hast, konfiguriert hast
Ich würde mich brennlich interessieren
Guck mal im Archiv vom Sebaro
Da gibt es einen Stream wo wir diese VM hier zusammen eingerichtet haben
Von Installationen
Bis so wie es jetzt ausschaut
Was macht Big Chuck eigentlich gerade so
So also wir starten erstmal T-Max
Lassen hier mal den Temperatursensor oben mitlaufen
So und jetzt starten jetzt machen wir einfach mal keine Ahnung
Echo 2 hoch, hoch ganz viel
Gepalpt nach BC
Oh Motherfuck
BC ist nicht drauf
Wusste ich gar nicht dass es Linux Installationen gibt wo BC nicht installiert ist
BC ist ein simpler Taschenrechner
Und wir starten das jetzt einfach 4x
Nebenbei machen wir hier noch einen Hardtop auf
Dass wir sehen wie ausgelastet der ganze Mist ist
Wir machen das anders wir machen das Hardtop hier unten auf
Dann sieht man das nämlich schöner
So und hier oben sagen wir jetzt Echo 2 hoch blubb BC
Und jetzt sieht man schon der erste CPU Kern ist am Brummen
Und das ganze machen wir jetzt 4x
Und jetzt sehen wir alle 4 CPU Kerne sind am Brummen
Und jetzt schauen wir mal wie warm es wird
Wohlgemerkt Umgebungstemperatur hier im Arbeitszimmer sind gerade 26 Grad
Weil ich die Klimaanlage an habe
Also es ist jetzt nicht ganz so warm wie wenn jetzt irgendeiner in der Dachwohnung ist
26 Grad ist gerade ganz angenehm
Na guck mal guck wie warm er wird
Ich mein er ist jetzt er ist auf jeden Fall ordentlich am Brummen gerade
Welche Klima hast du ich weiß es nicht mehr genau welcher Typ
Was eine von mir zu Bishy Heavy
Die Musik die bis gerade lief das ist irgendein Zelda Song of Storms eine Stunden Cover
Auch die Temperatur ist eigentlich ok
Raspberry Max CPU Temp ab wann mag die CPU dann nicht mehr
Ich glaube 95 oder sowas
85 nicht 95 85 war es
Da haben wir noch ein bisschen Raum
Ja ich habe eine fest installierte ich könnte noch drei Räume und mehr dran anschließen
Ich habe aktuell nur das Arbeitszimmer und das Schlafzimmer
Dove Frage hat die Temperatur irgendeine Aussagekraft
Wichtig ist doch eher ob er drosselt oder nicht
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob der Raspberry Pi sowas wie drosselt überhaupt kann
Ich gehe davon aus wenn er zu warm wird und da wird mit Sicherheit noch die ein oder andere Grad Toleranz sein
Auch ab 85 ich weiß nicht ob er drosselt aber er wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann abkacken
Oder zumindest hast du ultra lecks also ultra ruckeln
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal kein gutes Zeichen wenn er jetzt bei 85 Grad warm wird
Das ist glaube ich auch auf Dauer bestimmt nicht förderlich für die Lebenszeit von dem Ding
Ja werden wir ja sehen
Sollte er schlagartig ab irgendeiner Temperatur nicht mehr warm werden sehen wir das
Ansonsten können wir uns auch die CPU Frequenz angucken da müsst ihr jetzt aber das Kommando mir mal raussuchen
Wir können auch noch den Linux Scheduler umstellen dass der auf Performance steht dann taktet sich da auch nichts mehr rum
Was zum Teufel ist das für eine Frequenz
Das Ding müsste 1,7 Gigahertz oder so haben was ist das
Ah guck mal hier kann man sich so anzeigen lassen ob der irgendwie gepremst oder so
Oder möchte er uns gerade sagen dass die CPU Frequenz 600 Mhz ist
Welches Programm nutzt du zur Materialisierung also das ist ja gerade vor allem bei Workstation
Wir können den Scheduler noch auf Performance stellen
Mal kurz gucken wie das funktioniert hat das macht man nicht alle Tage
Ich bin gerade nicht in der Lage den Scheiß richtig zu treiben
Wie ging das mit dem Giga ja genau so war das so ging das Stack Overflow beste und Stack Overflow und hier Stack Exchange beste
Der läuft anscheinend wirklich schon mit 600 Mhz
Oder was sagt uns Frequency 48
Antwortest du auf Stack Overflow ne
Haben wir da eigentlich CPU 0 0 1 2 3 mehr sollten wir nicht haben
Ne okay anscheinend anscheinend ist er mit 600 Mhz aber so wirklich warm wird er nicht wir können das jetzt mal killen und gucken auf was er wieder runter geht
Jetzt hat er keine CPU Last mehr drauf jetzt sollte er eigentlich direkt direkt runter droppen
Jetzt läuft guck mal der taktet sich wirklich runter der taktet sich anscheinend irgendwie runter wenn wenn viele wenn alle Kerne ausgelastet sind
Vielleicht hat er sich schon vielleicht hat er sich nämlich schon gesrottelt
Das kann das kann sogar sein
Also ich wüsste nicht dass das der sowas hat wie nennt sich dieses minimalistische Desktop Environment das ist Manjaro mit i3 WM
Schauen wir mal Schauen wir uns mal den Clockspeed an ab wann der denn anfängt runter zu gehen
Was zum Teufel warum
Warum trosselt sich das denn
Keine Ahnung oder ich habe irgendwie Bauchweh ich muss ich muss noch mal kurz kurz ab
Ich lasse ihn jetzt noch mal kurz hier volle Pulle volle Pulle rechnen wir lassen ihn mal alle alle Threads
Er machte mal ein bisschen dampf ja ich bin auch mal kurz weg
Okay alles gut wieder am Start gab es dort Asiaman ne eigentlich gab es dort Pizza aber das sollte es sollte eigentlich nichts sein aber gut kann ja immer mal immer mal passieren
Ich habe noch eine Idee gehabt warum unser warum der Raspberries trosselt vielleicht das vielleicht das Stromversorgung ist zu schwach das kann auch sein
Deswegen ich schalte jetzt mal aus und schließt den an ein anderes Netzteil an
Ich meine das Netzteil sollte hinhauen das ist die Steckdose die ich euch zuletzt gezeigt habe aber mal gucken ich mache den jetzt mal aus und dann schauen wir uns das Ganze noch mal an
Also kurz umstabseln
Aber der ist aus
Schauen wir mal ob es jetzt besser ist
Der 3 Ampere braucht da maximal der sollte aber definitiv nicht anfangen auf 600 runter zu gehen wenn nur ein Kern unter Unterlast ist
So da ist er wieder schauen wir mal
Temperatur dann brauchen wir noch einen Vc Gen Glock da stimmt was nicht
Das liegt jetzt am Governor performance
Jetzt haben wir 1500 bc
Das sieht doch jetzt schon besser aus jetzt trosselt er auch gerade nicht mehr
Ja so ist doch schon besser
Jetzt wird jetzt wird er auch gleich ein bisschen wärmer
Das lag am Netzteil
Jetzt wird er nämlich auch gleich eine ganze Ecke wärmer jetzt läuft er nämlich auch mit vollem Takt
Er wird wärmer 71 Grad haben wir schon 71 Grad und dann gucken wir mal ob der Kühler irgendwas bringt
Aber er wird definitiv ordentlich warm
Das ist wirklich heiß das Ding
Also da kannst du den Finger nicht dran halten du kannst nur ganz kurz dran tippen das ist das ist ordentlich heiß
Ich meine es ist 76 Grad
76 75 ok erscheint erscheint sich 77
Wir könnten quasi mal versuchen ich könnte mal versuchen quasi live jetzt den Kühlkörper drauf zu stöpseln und dann mal gucken was passiert
Wieso ist die Temperatur irgendwie wichtig wirklich wichtig ist die nicht so lange der stabil läuft also sollte unter dem Strich stabil laufen und die performance bringen die man braucht ist die Temperatur egal
Man könnte vielleicht sagen dass die dass die Lebensdauer ein bisschen beeinflusst wird rein theoretisch aber ich glaube
Also rein rechter ich weiß ich ob es da überhaupt irgendwelche Vergleiche gibt ich glaube nicht dass über über tacken oder oder warm im Rahmen in der Spezifikation der CPU oder generell der Lebensdauer irgendwie großartig was ausmacht
So wir gucken jetzt mal ob wir vielleicht ich mache mal kurz die bc aus 1 2 3 4 mal bc an das hatten wir nämlich gerade schon
Und die Frage ist jetzt also es ist ja so wenn ich einen wenn ich den CPU mit vier kernen habe und ich starte mehr als vier Prozesse die ordentlich Leistung brauchen dann kann es durchaus sein dass wenn ich mehr also mehr als vier starte dass es dann langsamer ist
Weil das weil das multi das multithreading und das schedule im Hintergrund quasi so viel aufwärts erzeugt dass es nicht mehr so sehr prumpt ich weiß jetzt nicht wie es beim Respirator ist ob man da vielleicht mal probieren
Können wir sind bei 80 Grad komm ich starte ich starte jetzt noch mal zwei mal gucken was passiert
Macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied dann starten wir noch mal vier mal also wir sind jetzt bei 80 Grad
Okay ich weiß ich ob er mir damit sagen möchte dass er das er throttle
Es wird auch schon ein bisschen ein bisschen laggy
Machst du einen schönen Burn in quasi ja hast du den DHL mann gefragt
Es stand ja dann gestern in DHL drin dass das heute nicht mehr zugestellt werden konnte blabla
Nicht weil zu viel los war dass auf dieser Fahrt nicht zugestellt werden konnte oder irgendwas also unter dem Strich wollten sie mir damit sagen 82 Grad
Wollten sie mir unter dem Strich sagen dass zu viel das zu viel los war
Aber hier wird schon mal nichts gedrosselt das schon mal sehr gut
Okay jetzt werden wir mal gucken ob wir mit dem Kühler was machen können
Ich versuche mal ohne mir die Finger zu verbrennen ich meine das Ding ist immer 82 Grad heiß
Wenn ihr sich aufpasst verbrenne ich mir wirklich die Finger
Also das wird jetzt ein bisschen so von KS
Ich versuche jetzt mal den die Kühlrippen drauf zu machen
Aber ich schaue mal ob ich nicht doch irgendwo Raspberry Kühl
Ich habe doch noch Raspberry Kühlrippen weil ich habe alles ungefähr so grob thematisch in Cannons geschmissen
Und ich habe jetzt die Kühlrippen hier und dann habe ich die Kühlrippen hier
Ich zeige euch mal was für Kühlrippen wir zur Auswahl haben da können wir uns mal überlegen was wir probieren
Ja und KS gehen wir wieder weg die habe ich zur Auswahl und die werden halt explizit von Raspberry verkauft
Allerdings habe ich keine Ahnung was besser ist was meint ihr was wollen wir verwenden
Also das hier das sind irgendwelche Alu Kühlrippen und das andere sind auch Alu Kühlkörper
Also das ist auch kein Kopfer oder so das ist eigentlich egal oder
Eisegal
Dann nehmen die Alu ja ich nehme die Alu
Das andere ist halt noch ein kleiner dabei für die für diesen anderen kleinen Chip offen
Wie mit der besseren Bewertung 16 Grundbewertung 4,5 Sterne
Oh RIP
Okay dann nehmen wir die hier
Aber ich finde die die also potenziell sehen sehen die kühliger aus weil die größere Rippen haben
Hallo Fabi oder Fabi
Super Kühlleistung ich probiere die jetzt aus
Ich probiere jetzt einfach aus und guck mal dass ich mir nicht den Finger verbrenne
Ich habe jetzt genau rechtzeitig Bauchweh wo ich hier streng gestartet habe ganz tolles Timing
Das ist Massive Pepehands
Okay ich mach das jetzt mal dran in der Hoffnung dass ich mir nicht Finger verbrenne
Machen wir mal zu ob es runter geht
Alter ist das heiß
Alter ist das das ganze ganz sofort ey
Also ich muss jetzt mal an
Außerdem sind die Kühlrippen doch kacke sehe ich gerade
Die haben eine ganz kleine Kontaktfläche unten nur
Die andere nehmen
Ich nehme doch die andere
So hier
Es ist Tüte in Tüte in Tüte
Genau wir haben hier keine Grills wir haben Hotte Pies
Okay ich brauche irgendwas zum runterlegen
Okay jetzt jetzt mal ausprobieren
Und bringt es was
Massive bringt das was ey
Geht aber wieder hoch
Das hält jetzt genauso lang bis der Kühlkörper auch heiß ist
Mal leicht draufpusten auf den Kühlkörper
Na man hat es ja eben gesehen als ich den Finger drauf gedrückt habe ist es richtig kühl geworden
Okay
Aber
Na ja wahrscheinlich bleibt es ein zwei Grad kühler oder so
Ein bisschen kühler bleibt es oder so 2-3 Grad auch 3-4 Grad 3-4 Grad kühler
Gut aber das ist ja eigentlich nicht das was uns wirklich interessiert
Ich breche ich breche mal hier die Geschichte ab also wir haben daran schon mal gesehen der neue Raspberry wird verdammt heiß wenn man ihn ordentlich auslastet
Windows geh weg man kann ihn ja auch irgendwie übertakten zumindest die älteren konnte man übertakten ich denke mal der neue geht das auch noch
Okay dann testen wir jetzt mal
USB Geschwindigkeit würde ich sagen da machen wir hier neben den Mist mal zu und machen hier D-Stat an dann sehen wir was wir für Datenübertragungsraten haben und ich mache mal die USB Festplatte dran
Und dann schauen wir mal also USB hier SSD die SSD hat ja laut Test 560 Lesen 500 Schreiben die reicht zum testen
So schauen wir mal ob er die SSD erkannt hat
Ist das ein Gehäuse das ist gar kein Gehäuse der steht an
Okay Moment wenn das ups wenn wenn wenn das SDA ist was ist denn dann meine SD Karte ach Dings hier ja genau das ist gar kein Gehäuse ach so
Die SSD das ist gar nicht das ist das ist das ist einfach eine SSD eine MX500 SSD und das ist das ist einfach nur hinten das ist also keine Sache wo man das rein steckt sondern das ist einfach nur hinten so was zum dranklipsen wo dann ein USB Stecker dran ist China Kram halt
Okay testen wir mal HD
Also Leute tut mir leid es kann sein dass ich gleich noch mal auf Klo muss ich habe jetzt aus nicht erklärlichen Gründen irgendwie 2,5 Stunden brauchen HD paar Minus TT das ist so Test der nicht all zu viel aussagt aber gucken wir mal trotzdem was der hergibt
Ja das stimmt nicht das ist jetzt okay das ist Cash Reads Alter Leute ich muss noch mal aufs Klo sorry geht nicht anders
Okay
Okay also Buffer Discrete 246 MB die Sekunde sind ein bisschen enttäuschend probieren wir mal was realistisches aus also wir machen jetzt erstmal ein File System drauf
Ich kann kein Ex Ich kann kein XFS erzeugen
Too much information Tja manchmal Was meine ich für Informations immer kriegen ganzen Tag
Okay ich weiß dass dann falls es dem drauf ist aber das war überschreiben
Okay und es schreibt jetzt die den wir da einfach mal rein und gucken wir mal wie schnell das ganze funktioniert dann ist hier ein File System von 500 G
Okay und dann gucken wir mal wie schnell das ganze funktioniert dann ist hier ein File System von 500 G
Aber nicht so schnell
Ist dran, gucken wir mal
Undervoltage detected, das ist an einem richtig ordentlichen Netzteil mittlerweile dran
Ich glaube das Undervoltage hat er bloß, Moment, hat er die, er kennt da irgendwie die Disk nicht, kann das sein?
Er kennt da irgendwie die Disk über die Chacoongeschichte nicht?
Sieht fast so aus
Ja bei 3,5 Zoll brauchst du auf jeden Fall deinen eigenen Strom
Es gibt so komische Konstruktionen, die dann zwei USB Anschlüsse nehmen und sowas, aber das ist alles sehr...
Der erkennt die SSD nicht, wartet mal, was ist das?
Das? Änderloses Netz? Was ist das? Oh, USB, auch dran? Achtung, aus!
Das juckt dir nicht, das Chacoongehäuser, die SSD über das Chacoongehäuser erkennt er gar nicht
Jetzt, Moment, ahhh
Leute, das ist wieder, das ist, der Fehler sitzt oftmals vorm Bildschirm, das Problem war nicht, dass ich nicht richtig angeschlossen habe, sondern, dass ich das externe Netzteil nicht eingeschaltet habe, für den Wechselrahmen
Da kann natürlich der Kram auch nicht funktionieren, ok, Mount und DD, BÄM, gleich ein D-Stat hinterher
Ok, der Schieneadapter ist sackt, der Schieneadapter ist bisschen, bisschen, was ist das da jetzt? Jetzt bricht es übelst ein
Ja, so 300, so ungefähr im Durchschnitt 300 MB, das ist ok, WriteCache-Folger, das kann durchaus sein
Was ist denn, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist, USB Attached, SCSI oder, ja das ist wahrscheinlich das, aha, habe ich mich noch nie mit beschäftigt, wusste gar nicht bis eben, dass das überhaupt gibt
Ok, aber das Sharkoon-Gehäuse ist deutlich besser als der Schieneadapter
Was wir jetzt ja nochmal testen müssen ist, wie das mit zwei SSDs an zwei unterschiedlichen, das könnten wir noch testen, oder?
Wie sieht das mit zwei SSDs aus, wenn, also quasi, wenn an USB 3, an dem ersten Anschluss der SSD hängt oder an dem zweiten Anschluss der SSD hängt?
SSDs Langlebigkeit, absolut top, meine allererste SSD lebt immer noch, funktioniert immer noch, SSD Lebenszeit ist überhaupt kein Problem
Wie viele Rahmenverwendungen? Wahrscheinlich nicht viel
Nö, nix, war gut von Wasser auch
Also ich denke mal, dass, ich mein, muss ich mal überlegen, also 315 MB über USB 3 ist ok, 3-M sagt das gleiche, 3-M sagt 100 MB oder so, nix
Und ich denke, ios, das, what the fuck
Ok, auch in welchem Paket das auch immer wieder drin ist, ios
Was ist denn in iotop drin?
Hä, ne, ne
Das, das, das, die Anzeige ist hier, passt nicht
Komm in Ordnung
Das ist zwar ein bisschen fail hier oben, die Anzeige, das ist aber ok, was soll daran schlimm sein
Ich sehe da jetzt nix wildes, außer dass er das, was unter Niedungsüblich ist, die Sachen halt nicht direkt freigibt, erst wenn es angefreift wird, das ist ja das Interessante und das ist im Prinzip nichts vom Rahmen gebraucht
Oder meinst du das hier
Achso, ja, das, das
Jaja, das leuchtet
Ok
Stimmt, außerdem muss man available gucken
Ja, aber das hier ist das, das hier, das ist ja immer so, dass der, dass der nix, nix im Endeffekt freigibt, bis einer fragt
Ok, wir probieren es jetzt mal mit der zweiten SSD noch aus
Das ist schon dem hier ein Buster, ja
Wird ja auch empfohlen für den Pi 3
Also ich denke einfach mal, dass 315 MB die Sekunde, zumindest mit diesem, mit diesem Wechselrahmen, den ich hab
Recht, eigentlich sind die recht gut, wenn man sich überlegt, das war vorher USB 2 mit, mit irgendwie 20 MB oder 30 MB die Sekunde totalen Crap
Hiermit kannst du wirklich leben
Wir gucken jetzt mal, was passiert, wenn man zwei SSDs anschließt
Ich hab leider nicht mehr eine ganz so gute da, allerdings zum Testen reicht das erst mal
Ich hab noch hier ne
Ich hätte noch zu bieten
Eine SanDisk
SSD plus mit 240G
Kannst du auch mal LAN Traffic plus SSD probieren, machen wir gleich
Noch lesen testen, ja klar, kann ich machen
Wir lesen aber
Ich mein wir hätten eigentlich auch dd sagen müssen, dass wir sunken wollen
Aber dem wir dd so lange haben laufen lassen, ist das eigentlich nicht so, nicht so wild
Also der war auf jeden Fall, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht alles in Cache gewandert, was wir geschrieben haben
Dd
Wir lesen noch mal, hier blub, blub bin
Off
Def Null
Ja, das sieht doch auch sehr ordentlich aus
Das sieht doch prinzipiell auch recht ordentlich aus
Ich mein, wir haben 315 MB lesen, 315 MB schreiben gehabt ungefähr
Und so 360, 360 MB lesen
Im Vergleich zu früher kann man sich da wirklich nicht drüber beschweren
Find ich auch hoa, Hovana, also für so ein kleines Kackding ist das wirklich in Ordnung
So, wir machen jetzt 2 SSDs dran und gucken mal wie sich das dann auswirkt
Schauen wir mal
Ein Schieneadapter und einmal dieses Fakunding
Ich glaube nicht, dass er das auf dem Cache schließt, das waren 40 GB
So, SDB, MKFS
X4, SDB
Ich kann gleich die Caches noch mal wegschmeißen
Okay
Ich mach mal ein zweites Mountverzeichnis
Hey Max, wie bist du auf dein Twitchnamen gekommen?
Äh, gibt's keine großartige Story dahinter?
Ich hab irgendwas genommen, weil es eigentlich ein privater Account sein sollte
Und hab irgendwas eingegeben, weil ich ja nie gedacht hab, dass ich den Account benutze
Jetzt heißt es dann Wubblors
Wubblors ist so ein typischer Max Friseur Schwachsinnenname
Mount, SDB auf MT2
Dann machen wir den jetzt mal auf beide SSDs gleichzeitig und gucken mal was passiert
Wir gucken vor allem mal, da gucken wir mal D-Stat mit zu
Okay, DD
Äh, hier, DD
Zero, bla bla bla
Und zwar nicht auf Bloop Bin, sondern auf MNT
Bloop Bin
Bam
Und auf MNT
Oh, es leckt schon ein bisschen rum
Ich merk's schon
MNT2 Bloop Bin
Okay
Parallel
Funktioniert das nicht
Vielleicht wollen wir das da oben ab
Hier, die SSD da unten ist einfach, warum ist die so lahm
TF, was ist das?
Hab ich's gemountet überhaupt? Nicht, dass ich auf die SD-Karte schreibe
Ja, hab ich
Ah, äh
Sand ist Crap, äh
Das ist doch keine SSD, das ist
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist
Hab ich schon eine andere SSD irgendwo
Also, irgendeine unbenutzte
Ich überleg grad, hab ich schon eine unbenutzte SSD irgendwo
Ich hab noch ein paar 32G SSDs, aber die werden noch langsamer sein
Der Rest ist alles in Benutzung
Warum, was ist das für ein SSD-Speed, das ist ja eklig
Hast du dir einen USB-2-Port? Nee, nee, die hängt genau unter dem anderen
Aber was wir schon sehen ist, wenn ich das parallel starte, das geht beides runter
Vorhin haben wir da oben 315 MB gekriegt
Also es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich, an beide USB-3-Anschlüsse was zu hängen
Ein Trim auf der zweiten SSD, die ist, ich mach mal nen Trim, aber
Die ist mehr oder weniger fresh, fast frisch aus der Packung
Macht man eigentlich, macht man eigentlich nen Trim
Ach, FS-Trim, oder? FS-Trim? Genau, FS-Trim war es
Ich glaube, da spielt, muss man das anmounten? Nee, kann ja nicht sein, dann können wir das
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das am China-USB-Adapter liegt
Das wird am China-USB-Adapter liegen, bzw. an den USB-Adapter, dass das nicht durchreicht, oder?
Kann man da auch sagen, man kann nicht Dev-SDA oder so sagen
Kann man das irgendwie
Muss auch mit Discard gebaut werden, okay, ernsthaft?
Da sieht man mal, wie wenig ich da mit Linux und SSDs bisher Probleme hatte und rumgefuddelt habe
Das heißt, man muss quasi Mount-Options-Discard machen
Wisst ihr mal, es ist doch manchmal nicht schlecht, dass wir Twitch-Chat am Start haben
Und im Vergleich zu den anderen Chats ist bei mir der Twitch-Chat auch relativ hilfreich
So, mountainware-stb, mach mal Options, minus O, und dann einfach nur Discard, tatsächlich
Und das geht jetzt?
Ich weiß nicht, ich sehe das gar nicht als Options jetzt
Ne
Ne, ne, ne, Moment, das mit Discard ist, dass er automatisch, dass er automatisch trimmt
Das ist auch, das ist auch irgendeine x4-Geschichte, keine x4-Geschichte
Wir können mal ein x4 drauf machen, wir machen mal ein x4 drauf, vielleicht bringt das was
In letzter Zeit mache ich eigentlich fast überall der xfs drauf, fragt mich nicht warum, weil
Mkfs, x4, auf dev-sdb2s
Ich denke aber auch, dass eher der USB-Adapter rumspackt
Febe ultra hilfreich, huge hilfreich
Installierst gerade einen extraen Speicher, damit du das spielen kannst, ja
Wir haben gerade USB-Übertragungsraten getestet, wir sind bis 370 lesen, 315 schreiben gekommen
Havana gucke ich gleich, ah ist fertig
Und jetzt habe ich gerade mal geguckt, wie es mit zwei SSDs parallel ist, das funktioniert allerdings nicht so gut
Das HD-Palm, und dann soll ich irgendwie nach Trim creppen oder so
Wow, fuck
Jetzt verschmerzen
Ist doch nicht minus L
ZFS wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren
Prostes L
Ihh, da haben wir es bald
Proste sie
Jetzt haben wir ja alles durch, letzte Variante
Trim
Könnte man jetzt draus ableiten, dass es Trim supportet?
Oder nicht? Ich habe das ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mich damit nie großartig beschäftigt
Die USB-Adapter werden es wahrscheinlich einfach nicht durchreichen, gehe ich mal von aus
Zumindest ist die andere SSD extrem lahm, die ist Müll
Die wir hier drauf hängen haben auf MNT 2
Probieren wir nochmal aus
Die ist lahm
Was macht Trim eigentlich Sektoren wieder freigeben oder Speicherzellen wieder freigeben?
Teste mal die zweite SSD am ersten Port alleine
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, das machen wir mal
Aber danach machen wir mal einen Netzwerktest
Wenn das nicht funktioniert, suche ich nochmal eine andere SSD, ich habe bestimmt noch irgendwo welche rumliegen
Aber nicht heute
Mount
SDA MNT 2 DD
Gucken
Es ist auf jeden Fall besser als davor, wenn die SSD nur alleine dran hängt
Ich habe sogar eins cheat, ich habe sogar so ein Anheft-Mikro
Ich finde das viel unterhaltsamer, 90% was anderen Twitch-Kanälen läuft
Es ist ein bisschen nischenmäßig, aber es ist fix, was mich interessiert
Okay, 100 MB die Sekunde kriege ich dahin
Ich mache jetzt noch einmal die andere SSD dran
Ich habe jetzt einfach mal den Port gewechselt und gucke mal, was die dann bringt
Und dann machen wir mal weiter mit Netzwerk
Ne, danach machen wir weiter mit Lux
Wir müssten eigentlich auch nochmal MD-Rate-Performance testen
Eigentlich müssten wir einen MD-Rate machen
Da drin einen Lux und dann darauf Samba, um so ein halbwegs realistisches NAS-Szenario nachzubauen
Lesen von SSD ist auch ziemlich schnell
Lesen, wir können mal lesen
MT2, Blup, 0
Also lesen geht schon mal viel schneller
Die bricht übelst, also diese San-Disk-SSD ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur Crap
Und das Ganze gegen ZFS testen
Ja, ZFS wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren
Auf dem Pi, ich meine in 4 GB kann man das schon mal machen
Wie gesagt, ich habe es ja im letzten Stream schon mal gesagt, dass das eigentlich so ein bisschen Mysterium ist
Dass du mit ZFS unbedingt hier irgendwie in zweistelligen und manche sagen ja irgendwie quasi
Manche sagen ja irgendwie unter 30 GB RAM brauchst du ZFS gar nicht betreiben, das ist eigentlich Blödsinn
Richtig viel RAM brauchst du bei ZFS eigentlich nur
Wenn du entweder De-Duplication machst, das braucht dann aber nicht nur viel RAM, das braucht richtig viel RAM
Weil er quasi die ganzen, die brauchen von allen einzelnen Blöcken quasi Hechtummen im RAM, dass er De-Duplication machen kann
Also das ist quasi richtig online live De-Duplication macht er ja bei ZFS
Oder halt wenn es viele Benutzer hat
Und du ordentlich Performance für viele Benutzer willst
Und du einfach nur lokalen in das hast, wo irgendwie die Family drauf zugreift
Dann reichen auch 8 GB und da reichen auch zum Testen 4 GB für ZFS
Und ECC braucht man für ZFS auch nicht
Ich weiß gar nicht wo die ganzen Gerüchte herkommen
ZFS ist schön wenn man ECC hat, aber dadurch wird es auch nicht schlechter als anderes
Weil wenn du jetzt sagst ok, ich habe jetzt ein Rechner ohne ECC
Ich mach da ein Fallsystem drauf oder sag mal ein MD RAID drauf
Oder irgendwas so was Klassisches, ein MD RAID mit irgendwie X4
Dann oben drüber und ich hab keinen ECC RAM
Dann ist ZFS nur weil es keinen ECC RAM hat nicht schlechter als das
ZFS profitiert von ECC RAM, aber es wird nicht schlechter als die anderen Sachen
Oder es wird nicht gefährlich auf einmal nur weil du keinen ECC RAM hast
Aber wenn es nur für die Families würde dann auch X4 reichen
Ja klar, klar
Wobei ich ZFS an sich ganz schön finde
Weil seit ZFS 0.8 ist es ein sehr schönes Paket aus RAID, Snapshots, Volume Management
Und jetzt seit 0.8 auch Verschlüsselung
Also das heißt du brauchst eigentlich nicht mehr drei verschiedene Tools
Sondern theoretisch reicht ZFS aus
Und das Snapshot Features für ZFS ist auch für Family Geschichten ziemlich praktisch
Ich würde mittlerweile immer nur noch ZFS und Linux nehmen
Ich hab sogar mal irgendwo gehört, dass es angeblich Gerüchte gibt
Dass FreeBSD auch die ZFS, die ZOL Implementierung benutzen will
Okay, ähm
Was hab ich gesagt was wir jetzt machen
Wir machen jetzt ein
Wir machen jetzt Lux, nee
Wir machen RAID
Keine Ahnung, ich mach die billige Sandisk SSD aber erstmal ab
Oh ich hab nicht anmountet oder
Ich glaub ich hab nicht anmountet
Das mag er in der Regel nicht
Okay
Netzwerk, genau
Ähm ja genau Netzwerk machen wir aber bevor wir Netzwerk machen
Testen wir erstmal die Performance wie es aussieht mit Lux und wie es aussieht mit RAID drunter
Das muss man einfach nochmal ausprobieren
Einfach dass es ein halbwegs realistisches Nass Szenario ist
Und spätestens dann werden wir wahrscheinlich auch eher Probleme mit der CPU Leistung als mit der
mit der USB SSD Performance haben
Äh okay, mounten wir den Kram mal wieder
SDB ist es jetzt, mounten wir auf Dings
DD
Gucken wir mal wie die Geschwindigkeit jetzt ist
Okay, so wie erwartet
So wie vorher auch
So um die 300
Schwankt ein bisschen
Aber das ist ungefähr die Performance die wir vorher auch hatten mit der Platte
Also können wir so um die 300
Um die 300 lesen äh um die 300 schreiben können wir erwarten
310, 315 schreiben
Und lesen
Und lesen, wir lesen mal parallel mal gucken was passiert
Ah gut, ich glaube da kommen wir jetzt ein bisschen an die USB Bandbreite ran
Die macht da nicht mehr so ganz mit
Oh und lesen
Bisschen viel
Der muss, wir müssen noch Dings angeben bei DD, wir müssen noch Sync angeben sonst ist das Müll
Ne ne ne das ist das Sync, Conf Sync meine ich genau
Dann ist es nämlich von Anfang an realistisch
Es ist beim Read wichtig, äh beim Write richtig, beim Read nicht
Schon versucht ob man gleichzeitig Switch und Youtube schauen kann mit dem Vierer
Ne ich hab da gar kein Monitor dran allerdings würde mich wundern wenn nicht
Ich mein man hat jetzt im Vierer ne schnellere CPU drinne
H264, H265, Decoder, MPEG 2 Decoder, gut VP9 Decoder hast du nicht
Das könnte natürlich ein bisschen auf die CPU gehen
Was du allerdings hast ist ne ordentliche Grafikkarte mit OpenGL
Das sollte der ganze Desktop von profitieren
4GB ist das maximale
Der Raspberry ist immer noch, ja der ist immer noch 64 Spit
Äh immer noch 32 Spit
Ja ich finde da, ich muss übrigens recht geben als Nass würde ich das auch nicht verwenden
Allerdings nichtsdestotrotz wollen das viele Leute als Nass verwenden
Und wir testen einfach mal so ein bisschen so ein halbwegs realistisches Nass Szenario
Ich würde jetzt gerne erst nochmal testen was die Performance mit Lux ist
Da muss ich mir aber immer gucken wie das funktioniert das kann ich mir immer aus dem Kopf nicht merken
Irgendwie Lux Create, achso haben wir das überhaupt drauf oder Crypt Setup, ne haben wir nicht
Hat der Raspberry auf irgendeine Art und Weise Hardware, AES oder sowas
Dass wir dann auch das richtige, richtige, äh
Genau wir machen ein OpenSSL Benchmark machen wir
Da sehen wir nämlich wieviel wir durchkriegen wo der meiste Datensatz ist
OpenSSL, war das OpenSSL Speed
Denken wir was anderes
MD4, Omega Lull
Was würdest du als einfachen lokalen Webserver auf dem Pi empfehlen
Als Webserver an sich empfehle ich immer Nginx, genau da gebe ich mir mit keinem Partie recht
Nginx beste, allerdings wenn du einfach nur eine statische Seite ohne was posten willst dann nimmst du das
Nein nein das nimmst du nicht ich sag dir gleich was du nehmen musst
Wie ging das
Ah das da brauchste, wobei das ist Python 2
Das da brauchste, easy
Oder mit Python 3, stimmt, die Python 3 Geschichte hatte TP Server glaube ich
Genau, entweder das da oder das da
Startest da einfach in dem Verzeichnis wo dein HTML liegt und auf Port 8000 die Fault mäßig wirds gesurft
Das ist das einfachste was du machen kannst
Python ist vorinstalliert, am besten startest du das in einem T-Max dass du dich auch ausloggen kannst wieder
Das ist das einfachste, da musst du nichts konfigurieren
Würdest du das auch in Production verwenden
Kommt drauf an für was, aber prinzipiell schon
Wenn das irgendein internes Tool ist, was irgendwie eine Handvoll Leute aufruft
Mit bisschen HTML und JavaScript
Ja
Wo würdest du das machen, warum nicht
Ich mein wenn man eine ordentliche Web Anwendung baut, sag mal irgendwas auf ASP.NET Basis oder so
Da ist ja ne Web Server schon dabei
Sag mal das ist nicht der Benchmark den ich meine
Nee ordentlich heißt nicht dass man automatisch dort net verwenden kann, du kannst alles verwenden
Du kannst auch Node verwenden oder Dings verwenden
Go
Ok ist es doch OpenSSL Speed
Mich wundert das OpenSSL Speed so unglaublich viel testet
Krypt Setup Benchmark meine ich nicht OpenSSL Speed
Krypt Setup Benchmark
Das meine ich, das ist dann nämlich viel schneller gelaufen
Hat der Node.js Entwickler nicht mal an einem TypeScript Server gearbeitet? Keine Ahnung ob er das gemacht hat
Selbst PHP ist mittlerweile ziemlich gut
Das ist aber ganz schön langsam
Das ist aber
Übelst langsam
Warum ist das so langsam
Ja du brauchst aber
Mit ISN hast du keine Ahnung 2500 MB die Sekunde aber
Das ist nicht angemessen
Der müsste schneller sein
Aus Bauchhaus würde ich sagen dass der ein bisschen schneller sein müsste
Also ich hätte schon gesagt dass man irgendwie so 100 150 MB oder so hinkriegen
Da müssen wir also mit den Werten müssen wir eigentlich auch gar keinen Look Setup testen das kannst du vergessen
So wir machen jetzt mal eine andere Musik
Oh hier das ist die
Die Weep Zelt da ist das
Okay
Dann machen wir lieber das an weil das ist richtig nice
Das vom 25. Nobileum finde ich viel nicer
Als das vom 30.
Ja das ist das richtige
Okay also damit müssen wir definitiv keinen Looks ausprobieren
Ich habe hier noch einen
H2 ne ne ne hc2
Gucken ob der das ist
So ein Ding habe ich noch da das ist quasi auch ein Single Board Computer
Allerdings mit einer anderen CPU eine andere Architektur drunter
Ich glaube er hat 8 Kerne oder so
Das ist eine komplett andere Architektur
Und der kriegt gerade so mit
Mit Looks
Und einem X4 drauf über Samba sogar kriegt er ganz knapp so die 100 120 MB voll
Der ist aber ich glaube der hat aber auch ein bisschen mehr Power als der Raspberry
Der hat was hatten der für Kerne
Genau 8 Kerne
Nee der hat irgendwie noch mehr dann die 4 davon 8 davon oder irgendwie sowas
Ich weiß es gar nicht was der hat zumindest der ist schneller als der Raspberry
Allerdings finde ich das ganz ehrlich also
87 MB Encrypt und 76 MB Decrypt ist schon lahm
Merkt man auf modernen x86 Prozessoren eigentlich noch den Performance Impact durch Verschlüsselung
Ja aber nur wenn man sich am unteren Leistungsspektrum bewegt
Also zum Beispiel das Board mit dem ich eigentlich vor hatte mein NAS zu bauen
Das hatte nur 2 Kerne und nur 2 Jiminy Lake Pentium Silber Dinger also quasi Atoms
Die haben zwar IS Beschleunigung allerdings hast du schon gemerkt dass die an die Grenze geraten sind
Wenn du MD Raid plus Lux plus Samba gemacht hast das war für 2 Kerne einfach zu viel
Das konntest du vergessen das war einfach zu viel für 2 Kerne
Also normalerweise merkst du es nicht fällt kaum ins Gewicht
Ich kann ja gerade mal aus Spaß bei mir lokal das machen
Das ist jetzt meine VM die wird nicht Zugriff haben auf alle Hardware Funktionen
Gucken wir mal
Das ist mein i7 8700K
Inner VM
Mal gucken was da jetzt rauskommt
Ein bisschen mehr
Ein wenig mehr schafft der
AES XTS ist das was ein was interessiert
Für Lux
Das da ist eigentlich das was für Lux interessiert
Mein i7 ist irgendwie 100 mal schneller als der Raspberry oder so
Das enttäuscht mich jetzt ein bisschen dass der Raspberry so lahm ist
Ich muss mal gucken vielleicht muss man da irgendwie irgendwas einschalten oder so
Vielleicht muss man da irgendwas einschalten
Ok ok Leute der alte Raspberry war noch langsamer mit Lux
Das ist ja erbärmlich die Geschwindigkeit die der hier drin hat
Enabling Hardware Krypto Support
Ok was auch immer die da treiben die kompilieren sich irgendwelche Dinger
Aber ich glaube nicht dass das jetzt wirklich zielführend ist
Und die könnten ihre Post auch mal ordentlich formatieren da erkennste ja gar nichts
Ja bei diesem Krypto Zeug kommt natürlich auch noch ein bisschen dazu dass es nur ein 32bit OS ist
Da sind ja recht große Zahlen die profitieren bestimmt von größeren Inns
Ich glaube der Raspberry ist für verschlüsselte Geschichte ist einfach Crap
Gut dann haken wir das mal ab dafür lohnt es sich nicht
Also dafür sollte man was anderes holen
Patrick das hier der Game das könnte natürlich auch sein dass das einfach in Raspberry noch nicht richtig drinne ist
Das ist ja auch möglich zumindest sind die Benchmarkergebnisse Crap
Guck mal hier sind sie schon am am am überlegen was man machen könnte
Da machen sie ja jetzt sind sie aber richtig krassen Hexer am Start
Vielleicht müssen wir uns das noch mal in ein zwei Monaten angucken vielleicht kommt da noch was
Letzte Woche reicht eigentlich hier bei Benchmarks Dings was was hat er tut hier gemacht
Am V8 Krypto Extensions are not enabled
Gibt es auch kein AES und kein Krypto Gut dann ist nichts mit schneller Verschlüsselung auf dem Raspberry
Crap genau bisschen blöd aber können wir nichts machen
Wäre ja auch zu schön gewesen
Ok ich kann es absolut nicht zuordnen ob das jetzt viel oder wenig ist es ist wahrscheinlich wenig
Es könnte es könnte aber auch sein dass vielleicht irgendwelche Respirant Sachen noch aktiviert werden mussten
Vielleicht geht es auch einfach unter 32 Spit Betriebssystem nicht
Weiß man nicht muss mal gucken was die Zukunft bringt aktuell sieht so aus als ist gerade dadurch das Ding für den Nass eigentlich nicht zu gebrauchen
Du kriegst dann wahrscheinlich haste maximal kriegste wahrscheinlich irgendwie keine Ahnung 50 MB oder irgendwie sowas durch
Da würde ich mir auch viel also ich meine es ist immer noch viel viel viel besser als jetzt irgendwie der alte Raspberry
Aber da würde ich wirklich was anderes nehmen
Da würde ich so ein Odroid HC2 nehmen wenn es etwas etabliertes sein soll oder man wirklich ordentlich Performance haben will
Kann man sich auch einen niedrigen Energieverbrauch x86 Sport nehmen
Die brauchen ja auch nicht viel die brauchen ja auch Eidl irgendwie 6 Watt
Es ist halt teurer als ein Raspberry
Ja ein Raspberry hier selbst die 4 GB Variante kostet irgendwie 65 Euro
Dafür kriegst du mit ach und krach wenn du super viel Glück hast und Angebot ist das Board
Das heißt du brauchst immer noch RAM brauchst noch ein Netzteil und brauchst natürlich letztendlich auch noch die SSDs
Die haben die Platten hier nach dem ne also der Raspberry ist und bleibt kein kein Nass Ding
Soviel können wir glaube ich sagen und durch fehlende durch fehlende Hardware Encryption finde ich ist Nass auch nicht nicht sinnvoll
Ich würde heute prinzipiell eigentlich kein Nass ohne also ohne dass mein
Bei einer Plattform auf dem ich mal Nass betreibe Hardware also IS und die üblichen Kryptosachen in Hardware kann
Außer man sagt so nach dem Motto ja ich mach das halt alles unverschlüsselt
Aber es hat eigentlich nur Nachteile sein Nass unverschlüsselt zu lassen
Das fängt schon damit an dass ich einfach mittlerweile aus meinem Nass theoretisch die Platten nehmen könnte
Und und in Müll schmeißen und sie könnte keiner lesen
Das sind einfach ganz praktische Sachen ich würde heute Nass nicht mehr nicht mehr unverschlüsselt laufen lassen
Das ist einfach easy selbst wenn die die Platte verreckt und du willst einfach sicher gehen ey
Scheiß egal was mit der Platte passiert im Prinzip kann mit der Platte mit den Daten auf den Platten keiner was anfangen
Du kannst die Platte auch mehr oder weniger wenn du ganz faul bist bei eBay versteigern ohne dass du sie vorher vibes
Wenn sie verschlüsselt ist macht es ich finde das Handling ist einfach easier wenn es nass verschlüsselt ist
Gibt es eigentlich eine Möglichkeit automatisierte saubere geupdatete Ubuntu-Server-Frames zu erstellen
Um die dazu zu nutzen irgendwelche Linus-Sachen schnell auszuprepeln ohne Angst zu haben die Frame kaputt zu machen
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was du meinst
Das einfachste um Sachen zu testen ist eigentlich du machst dir eine Ubuntu-VM und da drinne machst du LXC bzw. LXD-Container
Das sind quasi eigene Mini-VMs solange du halt eh nur Sachen unter Linux machen willst und nicht gerade neue Kernel-Module testen willst
Dann würde ich mir LXD-Container machen unter einer Linux-VM
Ich würde mir nicht für alles Linux-VMs machen
Ja guck es ist easy
LXC-Lounge ich kramme über das einmal LXC-Lounge, Ubuntu
Ich zeige dir mal das ist super einfach
So mal einfach installierst LXD, Snap, Install, LXD
Und dann sagst du hier LXD-Lounge irgendwie Tests, Tests, Linux
Dann lädt er sich einmal das Ubuntu-Base-Image runter
Das brauchst du aber nur einmal machen das nächste Mal geht das super schnell
Also der lädt sich das nur einmal runter
Und dann startet er dir einen Ubuntu 1804-Testlinux
Und dann sagst du LXC-Exec-Bash, Exec-Exec-Testlinux-Bash
Und dann bist du auf der Kiste drauf
Bist du auf deinem Testlinux
Und dann sagst du ok jetzt hab ich das ausgelegt ich brauch jetzt noch ein Testlinux 2
Ein bisschen rum
Und dann hast du ein Testlinux 2
Und die kannst du jetzt komplett zerstören und kaputt machen wie du willst
Und danach wenn du fertig bist sagst du einfach
Sagst du einfach LXC
Ich glaub du musstest vorher stoppen
Und danach delete
Die speichern den State bis du sie löscht
Das ist nicht wie Docker was quasi alles temporär ist
Mit LXD ist das halt mehr eine eigene VM
Und das find ich ist zum Testen angenehmer
Weil du einfach reingehen kannst, hast Paketmanagement, hast Inlet, hast alles da
So und install ist auch ganz einfach
Snap, install, LXC oder über deinen Paketmanager normal
Weil Ubuntu ist es schon im Repo dabei
Kann der auch so viel Speicherplatz nutzen wie du willst
Wenn du es das erste Mal startest musst du eh LXD Init machen
Und dann fragt er dich wo du speichern willst
Was du für eine Speichervariante verwenden willst
Wie du die VMs defaultmäßig ans Netzwerk hängen willst
Dann musst du einfach so ein Assistent durchklicken
Und wenn du nicht willst dass das Ding dir das System vollballern kann
Dann machst du das halt in irgendeinen extra Ordner
Oder irgendwie musst du ja mal was überlegen
Oder passt einfach auf
Das ist aber zum Testen sehr sehr praktisch
So, also wir haben jetzt ausprobiert dass
Das nass Crap ist
Warum
Ist mein Kabel Müll
Ich glaub mein Kabel ist Müll
Warte mich nicht was ich da für ein uraltäutiges Noob Kabel
Irgendwie ausgebundelt hab was nur mit 100 Mbits zwingt
Aber ich glaube nicht dass es am Raspberry liegt
Ich glaube das liegt am Kabel
Deswegen nehmen wir mal ein anderes Kabel
Umstecken
Hahaha Wahnsinn
Leute ich hab das ich glaube ich hab das kürzeste Kabel aller Zeiten gefunden
Moment jetzt muss ich euch mal fotografieren
Das kürzeste
Ja ich glaube das ist ein 25 oder noch kürzer
Es ist wirklich saumäßig kurz
Und ziemlich ungeeignet für
Aber es sieht schon sehr mickrig aus
Grad mal hochladen vom iPhone aus
Imigur Upload
Photolibrary
Ups
Was
M
A
Moment ich hab es doch richtig geschrieben
F
Warum geht das nicht
Warum geht die Uhl nicht
Debated
Debated
Share
Es ist echt übelst kompliziert
Ein Bild vom iPhone zu sharen
Warum ist das warum ist das so kompliziert
Ich krieg da echt immer Anfälle dabei
Brauche ja 5 Stunden um euch einfach mal ein Foto zu zeichnen
Ich kann die Page nicht öffnen ich glaube das ist irgendwie
Verbackt gerade
Ach so ach das ist ein O
Macht auch kein Unterschied
Verlust du keine Clouddienste doch aber da bin ich hier überall nicht drauf eingeloggt
Das ist mein Streaming Account
Da bin ich da bin ich nirgendswo drauf eingeloggt
Das ist auch gerade die Sache
Nee ich glaube im EGUR hat beim Upload gefällt
Weil genau das
Also ich krieg's ich krieg's gar nicht erst angezeigt
Nö ich krieg's gar nicht angezeigt
Ach Scheiß drauf es ist so ein so ein keine Ahnung 20cm
Minifurz Kabel was nicht funktioniert weil der Raspberry so weit weg ist vom Switch
Jetzt muss ich mir echt was einfallen lassen mich da ein ordentliches Kabel dran krieg
Wo habe ich denn ein ordentliches Netzwerk Kabel
Also ich habe hier eine Menge ordentliche Netzwerk Kabel die passen aber nicht dran
Ich hätte zum Beispiel einen FSP plus Direct Attached 10G Kabel zu bieten
Bringt mir jetzt allerdings nichts für den Raspberry
Ich sehe da was
Hier guckt Netzwerk Kabel raus
Das könnte angenutzt werden
Ausprobieren
Aber das reicht aber gerade so hängt der Raspberry voll in der Nase
Okay Netzwerk Kabel ist dran
Hängt jetzt voll in der Luft der Raspberry allerdings funktioniert's
Jetzt haben wir Gigabit
Macht direkt alles gut
Huge Netzwerk Kabel in der Hause
So aber jetzt sind wir auf Gigabit
Der hängt jetzt zwar ein bisschen behelfenmäßig hier quer durch Zimmer der Raspberry
Dass es bis zum Switch reicht aber ist für Tests ja wurscht
Link ist im Chat und funktioniert
Häh wo habe ich mich denn vertippt
Wo genau habe ich mich jetzt vertippt dabei
Bei dem Link
Ach
Tja das ist natürlich doof
Ihr guckt euch mal das Netzwerk Kabel an
Das ist wirklich das mickrigste was du haben kannst
Da ist übrigens die
Die SSD
Da ist der Raspberry dran mit der SSD drinnen
Da vorne ist die Steckdose mit dem Raspberry drin
Okay Netzwerk
Testen wir mal wie viel da drüber geht
So ich bin übrigens nicht auf Klo falls ihr das nicht gemerkt habt
Und Perf
Oh Gott das kann ich mir immer aus dem
Das kann ich mir immer aus dem Kopf nicht merken
Minus es ist genauso mit die Fall Settings aufmachen
Perf 3
Punkt 2 Punkt
Dann musste man
Minus 10 genau
Das ist okay
Das ist in Ordnung
Was er da an den Server schickt
Wahrscheinlich ziemlich leere TCP Pakete
Ich würde sagen TCP Pakete mit einfach nur 0 0 Payload
Aufgefüllt
Und was sagt der Raspberry Pi so
An sich ist er ziemlich gut
Allerdings für Netzwerk
Storage Geschichten nach wie vor
Leider nichts
Was daran liegt dass
Die Hardware Encryption in der CPU nicht funktioniert
Und man deswegen sein Lass nicht verschlüsselt betreiben kann
Was läuft da für Musik das ist die
25 Zelda Jubiläum Soundtrack
Ja und zumal ich das ja auch aus der vm ausführe das ist okay
Ich kann es mal ich kann es mal hier ausführen von Windows aus
Aber ich habe erst mal gucken ob ich das irgendwie installiert krieg
Aber wenn man das unverschlüsselt
Dann wird es laufen mit den neuen
Laufen ist da relativ laufen tut das ja mit dem alten auch schon
Auf dem alten Raspberry war es halt übertrieben lahm
Übers Netzwerk
Jetzt ist okay
Also ich denke wenn du es nicht verschlüsselt
Wenn du es wenn du es nicht verschlüsselt
Wenn du einfach nur
Irgendwie ein paar USB Platte dranhängst
Im Fall das Tim draufmachst und Samba draufmachst
Dann kannst du so denke ich mal so mit Canon 100 MB ungefähr rechnen
Also unverschlüsselt ist okay
Ja und USB 3 ist auch ordentlich flott haben wir vorhin ausprobiert
Wir haben über die SSD haben wir so 315 schreiben gekriegt
Und 360 lesen ungefähr
Das ist also wirklich in Ordnung
Also von Rofi beste Rofi habe ich im Einsatz für Launch Menü und für Clipboard Manager
Probieren wir das mal von Windows aus mal gucken ob es dann schneller ist
Minus C
Was 123
Ist genauso schnell
Also maximal kriegen wir über das Netzwerk Interface 100 so um die 110 MB
Ungefähr drüber
Und dann dort falls irgendwo
Ich hatte mal angefangen die ein bisschen hübsch zu machen für GitHub aber ich habe es irgendwo hochgeladen
Hast du voll Duplex getestet das ist voll Duplex
Ach nee du meinst IP Dings hier
Senden und empfangen gleichzeitig mit IP
Ja ne das haben wir nicht getestet
Das können wir mal testen
Muss ich das dann für zweimal starten
Hier das eingebaut
Wir testen jetzt noch mal was anderes
Ich lasse jetzt mal hier
Das laufen als Server
Und mach da mal vom Raspberry
Drift drauf
Was haben wir hier für eine IP von meiner VM
Macht
Macht nicht viel Unterschied
Ok dann testen wir das mal hin und zurück
Können wir mal machen
Weiß nicht ob man das dafür doppelt starten muss
Also doppelt starten kannst du es auf jeden Fall
Aber ich weiß nicht ob das vielleicht eine Option hat
Wo man sagen kann mach Server und Client irgendwie zeitgleich
Nee geht nicht
So dann haben wir es hier laufen
Dann haben wir es hier laufen
Dann machen wir hier Client hab ich schon wieder vergessen
Den da
Und hier machen wir IPerf Client
Achso Moment bin zu langsam
Wir sind
Das bricht schon ein wenn beides zeitgleich an ist
Was minus minus dual wirklich
Nee
Man kann doch IPerf count
Probe
Man kann ja bestimmt sagen dass man das öfters machen will
Aber wenn es IPerf 2 kann kann es leider bestimmt auch
Kann man da nicht so was sagen wie count oder Menge oder sowas
Minus minus dual test
Mit minus R kann man es quasi reverse machen
IPerf das schickt TCP Pakete zwischen zwei Reichen hin und her
Und misst wie schnell es maximal geht
Muss dem doch sagen können wie oft er das Ganze machen soll
Minus T
60 Sekunden
T 60
Okay
Aber du hast ja bei TCP eh schon immer ein bisschen senden und empfangen
Muss immer bestätigung verschicken
Aber gleich zum Zweier ist es ja wirklich schon welchen Unterschied dazwischen
Also ich glaube den kann man jetzt bedenkenlos empfehlen für einfache Netzwerkgeschichten die einfach ein bisschen Bandbreite brauchen
Also ein austestender Flusssteuerung
Also die Netzwerk Performance ist wirklich in Ordnung da kann man nichts sagen
USB Performance
USB Performance ist ziemlich gut 315 MB Schreiben 360 MB Lesen offene USB SSD Netzwerk Performance ist top mehr kannst du eigentlich nicht wollen
Encryption Performance ist Crap
Aber es lohnt sich als Nass einfach nicht
Suspension
Was ist für ein Kern
20.000
Reicht zackig hinkriegen
Versand bestätigung
Also das sollte jetzt schnell gehen die ersten tausend sollten auch ziemlich schnell gehen an die ersten 10.000
An an den steckdosen an den schienen an die schiener steckdosen ne an an den an irgendwas anderes ist er laut ich habe schon voll verdrängt
An den scam an den scam repeater ja da fühle ich mich aber heute nicht in der nage irgendwas hinzuschreiben ich gerade nicht kreativ genug
Wo hast du den entschränkten so schnell schon bekommen ich habe einfach als die meldung kam dass der jetzt raus ist direkt vorbestellt oder direkt bestellt
Was für eine story ist das mit dem repeater ich habe gestern so eine scam werbung gesehen wo sie den repeater verkaufen der angeblich der netzwerk 300 prozent schneller macht und die hat eine Kontakt email adresse wo man hinschreiben kann wenn man fragen hat
Da wollten wir eigentlich noch hinschreiben und mal ein paar blöde fragen stellen
Irgendwas funktioniert das auch mit meinem klasfaser anschluss kann kann das auch klasfaser oder irgendwie sowas doofes wo die dann erst mal denken was was antworten wir da jetzt
Bestellt habe ich hier bei denen habe ich schon viel raspberry zeug bestellt die sind nicht schlecht geht auch immer schnell allerdings ist alles ausverkauft
Ach nee guck mal die 1 gigabyte variant ist wieder da 47 also leute wenn ihr eine haben wollt
Schreibt in eure bestellt kommentarein hier von maxi hergeschickt da können die mich in zukunft sponsor sehen wir haben mehr oder weniger alles getestet
Stromaufnahme wollten wir noch testen ja das machen wir wenn ich mein messgerät mein usb strom usb strommeter ding
Pinde habe ich das da ich habe stromaufnahme testen wir noch das machen wir jetzt noch das interessiert mich
Mysterion haben ist erst mal besser als brauchen
Was ist das beste feature am neuen raspberry usb 3 eindeutig usb 3
Dicht gefolgt und je nachdem was man machen würde dicht gefolgt von einem ordentlich gigabit es hat
So ungefähr auf einer auf einer ebene allerdings ich würde fast schon sagen usb 3
Ne die neue cpu ist jetzt nicht so das ding also es ist nice to have die neue cpu die ist auch in der ecke schneller
Vor allem hat sie out of order execution sie taktet ein bisschen schneller es ist eine neuere generation die insgesamt ein bisschen schneller sein sollte
Aber die cpu reißt immer noch keine bäume aus und wo wir festgestellt haben anscheinend hat die cpu obwohl sie das eigentlich haben könnte
Laut hersteller keine hardware verschlüsselungs ob also einheiten drin das ist mist weil hätte sie das würde sich der raspberry als nass
Eigentlich ganz gut eignen wenn man keine allzu großen ansprüche hat für daheim allerdings da encryption extensions fehlen ist es halt
Der ist halt ultra langsam mit ultra langsam ist gemeint wahrscheinlich irgendwie so 40 mb die sekunde oder so vielleicht sogar weniger
Ich überlege da hat jetzt alle vier kerne gebraucht für für irgendwie 70 mb theoretisches maximum wenn da noch wenn da noch samba dazu kommt und
Da bist du wahrscheinlich aber 25 mb oder so als mediaserver wiederum würde ich sagen ist es ganz gut weil dort würde ich die platte auch nicht
Verschlüsseln ja also wenn wozu wenn da jetzt irgendwie fernsehaufnahmen oder sonst was draufliegen sei denn du bist ja der der krasse
Torrent sauger oder oder oder use net sauger und willst nicht dass irgendeiner feststellt was er dir so gesaugt hast dann muss das natürlich
Verschlüsseln aber mediaserver bräuchte man nicht unbedingt natürlich so wie ich euch kenne habt ihr selbstverständlich nur korrekt erworbene cds dvds
Und blu rays selbstverständlich auch ohne irgendwie illegales umgehen des kopierschutzes gerippt auf externe platten deswegen ist es auch kein
Problem damit es auch nicht verschlüsseln soll ich guck mal wie viel strom der raspberry braucht das probieren jetzt wirklich gerade noch mal
Ich starte das teile ich habe gerade mein jetzt hat runtergeschmissen mein mein verlängerungs ding ich hoffe es war jetzt nicht zu laut
So kann ich machen also eidl haben wir das muss ich wieder aufstehen man sieht das leider nicht richtig von hier
Eidl brauchen wir 600 milliampere bei 5 volt usb
Wohlgemerkt wer beim esp 32 arduino programmier stream dabei war der wird sich auch daran erinnern können unser esp 32 das board was wir haben hat 11 microampere gebraucht im sleep
So sieht es aus krypto meister
Das hier kann es mal eben echo scale bc ausprobieren ja kann ich machen mal gucken ich gucke mal drauf strom vom einkehr
Ja würde ich hier nehmen würde ich nebenbei daneben setzen freiwillig
Ja eine time wäre nicht schlecht das stimmt
21 sekunden ja das ist ja im prinzip das entscheidende das ist für musik
Ein ton okay wir machen jetzt noch mal unser pc an guck mal was nur die maximale
Was ist für pornmusik
So jetzt geht die temperatur wieder hoch mal gucken was er jetzt verbraucht
Also da braucht jetzt 1,2 ampere das ist in ordnung für vier kerne voll ausgelastet da muss man sich keine gedanken machen auch mit ein bisschen schlechteren netzteil
Gut wir können jetzt nicht genau messen er hat bestimmt ein paar spitzen zwischendurch die wir jetzt auf dem usb messding nicht sehe
Schön auch nachheizen kein problem ich habe eine klimaanlage an ich heize und kühle gleichzeitig
Wir machen heute ein bisschen früher schluss ich werde mir kurz was was kleines zu essen machen
Aber ich denke wir haben doch zum größten und ganzem das durchgekriegt was wir machen wollen wir werden noch mal in einem der nächsten streams mal die
Summer Performance testen mal schauen wie gut das ist aber alles in allem ist der neue Raspberry Pi ziemlich gut nur halt für nass eigentlich immer noch nicht zu gebrauchen
So würde ich das mal bewerten
Okay Leute ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen wir machen noch ein bisschen früher schluss ich gehe jetzt off und mal gucken ob der stream diesmal mit dem hosten funktioniert
Und mich nicht wieder einschaltet danach das war ja gestern auch was oder einmal war ich wieder on
Oh eine donation da muss ich noch mal kurz gucken 2 Euro vom Flo money money money easy money easy life weißt du auch
Gibt es da irgendjemand den man hosten könnte eine das von denen wo ich follower
Ist gerade nichts dabei der link to the past randomizer ist schon mehr oder weniger vorbei
Na gut Leute wir machen noch ein bisschen früher schluss ich habe immer noch ein bisschen Bauchweh ich weiß nicht von was ob es von der Pizza ist
Ich bin jetzt auch gerade nicht mehr so motiviert irgendwie großartig was zu machen wir sehen uns dann weiß ich nicht ob morgen aber auf jeden fall am Wochenende wieder
Okay bis dann macht's gut